طويل لدى بوتين واطول منه لدى الاوكرانيين
وبنهايته ابتعدت جدا احلام العوده الى
الشهر الاول من الحرب الاوكرانيه الرابعه
عشر من مارس روسيا تستولي على 27% من
اوكرانيا اكثر من ربع البلاد من الجنوب
بمساحته الزراعيه الشاسعه وتحديدا في
خرسون الى الشمال محطه شرنوبل وممر بري
يصل الى حافتكيف كانت هذه ذروه النجاح
الروسي ومن قمته جاء السقوط الحر في ابريل
الى قاع الفشل على ابواب العاصمه
الاوكرانيه انسحب الروس من شمال وشمال شرق
اوكرانيا في الثامن من ابريل لتبدا
المرحله الثانيه كما اسمها بوتين بخساره
اربعين في المئه من مكاسب الميدان من مايو
وحتى نهايه اغسطس خطوات بطيئه في الشرق
حققت مكسبي ماريوبول نهايه مايو ولوجانسك
مطلع اليوم لم يستشعر بوتين في غمار
محاوله جيشه السيطره على دنيا العاصفه
القادمه من خركيب العاشر من سبتمبر اكبر
تقدم للجيش الاوكراني في يوم واحد على
حساب انسحاب الروس في الشمال الشرقي باكثر
من 50 كيلومترا والمساحه تحمل اهميتها
انسحب الجيش الروسي من مدينتيوم وكوبيانس
المركزين اللوجستيين اليدومباس في اسبوع
واحد فقط من الهجوم المضاد كانت المكاسب
الاوكرانيه من الاراضي اكبر مما استولت
عليه القوات الروسيه في الاشهر الخمسه
الماضيه هل يعني ذلك ان روسيا تخسر الحرب
لا الضمه لاربع مقاطعات انقضها واكسبها
مئه وسته عشر الف كيلو متر مربع طبعا مع
القرم ونتحدث هنا عن مساحه دوله بحجم
بلغاريا غير ان المكسب او ربعه لم يدم
طويلا في العاشر من نوفمبر تنسحب القوات
الروسيه من خرسون وهي اول مقاطعه سقطت تحت
السيطره الروس تخليها مع محيطها على طول
الضفه الغربيه لنهر ديني برو موسكو سحبت
اربعين الف جنديا من المنطقه
باستعاده خرسون تواجد اوكرانيا مكاسبها من
هجومها المضاد مسترجعه وخمسين في المئه من
اراضيها لكن الحرب رمال متحركه في الخامس
والعشرين من يناير الماضي القوات
الاوكرانيه تنسحب من سولار شرقا بعد
اقتحام قوه فاغنر المعادله العسكريه
الروسيه بقوه وتصدرها مشهد الحرب في اعقاب
التباطؤ الشتوي المكسب مهم سوليدار بدرجه
اقل المكسب الحقيقي على بعد عشره كيلو
مترات ولاجله سجلت اكثر المعارك دمويه في
الحرب